[Music]
hello marilyn you're on the air
hi what's up hey so i
um i went to uh i've been having
shoulder pain i went to actually the
chiropractor they took an x-ray
and they showed that i have some
calcification on my
humerus is near the um near the um
the lesser tubercle and i've been on the
heavy hamburger
brain and health packs with selenium
kilobiology
and all that so i know that's really
working for me my question to you is
that
i'm i had started to sleep on my
shoulder
by sleeping on my shoulder does that
decrease the cause compression and
possibility can decrease the blood flow
in those areas and probably not okay
how old are you and how much you weigh
i'm
50 and i weigh 100 and about 60 57
pounds
okay 157 pounds sure do you have any
other issues
high blood pressure diabetes bowel
problems skin problems
no i've been using your product and i
was having some issues i don't have
those issues anymore i continue to take
it i've gotten better and
in all aspects i'm surprised to have
okay now okay now charmaine what would
you add to
marilyn's program to help you know
rebuild
the cartilage ligament tendons
connective tissue in her joints and
bones
and for her bones to reabsorb any like
bone spurs and extra calcification
and and re-architecture back down to
normal what would you add to her program
well she's not taking it i would take
the msm and i would also take the
i take the keltatti but or us to fx
either one
yeah okay so yeah 157 pounds
you could take a um either a half ounce
or an ounce of the cal toddy
uh twice a day sure is exactly right the
msm i'd go ahead and take three of those
with each meal that's two bottles a
month
that's going to help re-architecture the
bones in other words there's something a
little bit wrong there
and so by taking the msm and the extra
calcium your bone is going to do a good
job of putting everything back to where
it belongs
it's not unusual um when people
have bone spurs and extra calcium
calcification here there and yawn
there's some basic little thing going
wrong there by adding
extra calcium to your diet and adding
the msm
to your supplement program give us a
call every two weeks
and if you have pain what would you have
her use over her
arm where she has the pain what would
you have her do to
reduce or eliminate the pain i put some
trauma oil in the cm cream and use that
that works yeah the same cream you had
to mix it up real good because the cream
settles at the bottom and the water
comes to the top every night so you need
to stir it up with a straw or a
toothpick or something
and then for every teaspoon of the same
cream you apply to a sore spot
in a joint or anywhere in your muscle or
bone
you do want to add five or six drops of
that trauma oil shar says
and call us every couple weeks and let
us know what's going on
as you age factors like health weight
diet and lifestyle
can all impact your bones joints and
general mobility
even everyday exercise can lead to wear
and tear on your body
over time you might start to experience
stiffness or pain due to damaged joints
or connective tissue
ultimate glucogel by youngevity was
created to help you limit the effects of
wear on your joints
it delivers a daily dose of collagen
rich gelatin your body needs for joint
elasticity
and maintenance ultimate glucose gel
contains a one to one ratio of gelatin
and glucosamine sulfate
which is a key building block of your
bone matrix cartilage
ligaments tendons and connective tissue
gelatin's unique blend of amino acids
not only help with muscle and joint
health
but also has been shown to provide
additional benefits for the brain
skin and hair ultimate glucogel
natural optimal daily support for joint
health
to learn more contact your youngevity
associate
[Music]
a strong heart is a happy heart your
body systems depend on a healthy
cardiovascular
system to thrive without a healthy heart
you could experience symptoms like
fatigue
aches and pains dizziness or shortness
of breath
proper nutrition is crucial to your
cardiovascular health
youngevity developed ultimate efa plus
with a proprietary balanced blend of
essential fatty acids
from borage flax and fish oils to help
make sure you get the nutrients your
heart needs
we started with flaxseed oil it's been
shown to improve the elasticity of
arteries and support healthy blood
pressure
next we included cold water fish oils
rich in omega-3s that can promote a
healthy cardiovascular system
and even increase levels of good hdl
cholesterol then we added borage oil
known for its powerful anti-inflammatory
properties
blended together these essential fatty
acids provide you with the
optimal blend of nutrients to help
maintain normal cardiovascular health
ultimate efa plus the right nutrients to
improve your heart health
naturally to learn more contact your
youngevity associate
[Music]
you